[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was all love except when it wasn't
but either way Love Wins at the end of
the day and that day has come everybody
because we have a winner
spoiler alert here's who won season one
of love island the winners of love
island 2019 are
[Music]
Zach and Elizabeth
[Music]
[Music]
hey sexy beaches welcome to the final
episode of love after the island your
official love island recap show i'm
lauren zima here to spill all the
tropical tea on this last week of love
island airing only on CBS and CBS all
access now coming up we have an
exclusive interview with zack and
elizabeth themselves and we are taking
your questions and comments live all
episode long here on love after the
island you can leave them on youtube and
you might have a few fiery things to say
to our sexy yes joining me now in our
cozy cabana here in Burbank California
to Big Brother fan favorites and a
couple themselves Bailey Dalton is
swaggy CR here and the Islander who
ultimately cashed in on her love card
Kira green oh my god you're fresh off
the island girl I just got here know
what by the way we are also joined for
our viewing fun by some Big Brother
alums and former Islanders themselves so
they had a little viewing party all on
their own
hey you guys what up yes yes yes we had
a man down there alright but it's all
over guys Zack and Elizabeth are the
winning couple and we have their first
yes applause position they ended up in
love they dropped the album to each
other in the beginning like they were
just done two so I mean it made sense
like to me uh let's take a look at the
very first things they had to say
straight from the villa after they won
and jumped in the pool I'm still in
shock I can't believe that this
experience
yeah I mean this is truly incredible I'm
so grateful for this experience I'm so
grateful for all the friendships that
I've gained in here I'm so grateful for
this one she means the world to me and I
can't wait to experience the life
outside of here with her honestly we're
gonna have a great day I just didn't see
this coming I thought that exact same
sentence in my head I was gonna say it
if she didn't we're probably gonna get
married in like six months
no I don't know we're right now we're
just taking things one step at a time I
think we are both at points in our lives
where we need to evaluate what we're
gonna do and what steps we're going to
take but we're gonna be there for each
other supporting each other so whatever
happens happens but we got each other's
backs at the end of the day meeting me
yeah meeting meeting Elizabeth was
amazing
and one of my favorite parts of this
whole journey was when Elizabeth got
asked to go out on a date and she came
back from that date and we had this
little moment in the bathroom and that's
like when I knew that this relationship
was gonna be what it was that was just
like one of our I think defining moments
in here and I'll never forget that
moment
[Music]
I I'm probably gonna use most of my
money because I have some student loans
to pay off
and and then I'd like to like start a
business with with with if I have money
left over I like to start start my own
business so cannot wait to just explore
with you and I'm just so happy
Zach be joining Elizabeth on her
European but I did love at the end of
the day they were given the option you
know are you going to keep all this
money or split it and I think both of
them would have split it they seemed so
in love from the start you guys I mean
you were fans and viewers and we could
sense that through the screen the whole
time yeah we were screaming we're like
we know that exactly what was put it not
some other couples who do you think
would have kept it Westen oh Emily yep
potentially really yeah we said Dylan
and Oh Alexandra would have split in
their doing but what are you doing well
here you are fresh off the island so
tell us in person that love between Zack
and Elizabeth how did you guys observe
it right from the start all the way to
the yeah it was immediate like right off
the bat they coupled up with each other
and they were just in their own world
like everyday sense like the boys would
get upset I was super close to her when
I first came in there and I was just
like so happy like they were in their
own world from like day one I keep
seeing they're both such beautiful
people but because they are so good to
each other I found them even more
attractive as the whole seasons honor
they're gonna have the gorgeous shoulder
together we're probably gonna get
married in six he's a home grown boy oh
yeah yeah he's probably serious like
it's like he's from the Midwest which is
where I'm from and we get married and we
have babies immediately so like he's
used to that yeah do you see that really
happening for them I mean Zack is very
like
he's very serious about it he said I
love you first like he's doing all the
right things okay well the three
remaining couples may not be walking
away with that prize money of $100,000
but they are walking away hand-in-hand
and may be falling in love here's what
the top Islanders told ET exclusively
about love and life after the island
losers you know win some lose most where
we're happy I mean we get to leave with
each other at the end of the day so I
wanted to cover first wanna start to
finish we feel absolutely amazing it's
been a greatest experience of my life
okay well here's to but money was never
the option you know there was never a
thing for us we just were happy where we
are doesn't meet a dog yeah I know it's
gonna be a lot of fun and I know we're
gonna get along well so I just hope with
the distance I don't know two hours
which is nothing it works out
sure well roll with the punches hey like
me know America my hope is that our
relationship keeps flourishing you know
that our connections keep sitting
and I'd you know I'm ready to get out
here and we just learn what Carol is
about like we have two different lashes
in LA I was in New Jersey but we all
make it work and I'm just excited also
to meet Bisou hello Kara we want to see
the traveling climbing up mountains
jumping off cliffs Stewart's doing
anything for more sharks flying
helicopters and just making bacon my
school and I am excited to see where
things are awesome but no favorite
physical moment was definitely on the
helicopter is amazing glad to be here
when you walking through the doors that
honestly changed my whole journey my
favorite part was like this new day like
thing we took care of our baby quest
yeah baby she let the parents and we
went on our epic date it was just lit as
hell I had a great time and it has so
much fun with Kara like Larry that was
like the best
yeah it was she's a big part of it
meeting all these amazing people and
just having the experience you have this
villa experience it's like a family to
me just taught me the law I love seeing
some of those moments who know ray got
so excited to picture having a baby with
Kara families with the babies like you
literally they were actual parents I
think we can all agree we loved Cairo
fresh she was an OG
I feel good about her finally finding
Rey do we feel good about right I'm like
kind of from Germany played like college
basketball there and he's right from
there so like we have the same
personality so like I know him and Cara
are gonna work okay well let me ask you
though they do have that long distance
we were talking about that East Coast
West Coast you move for her right yeah
could we see we see rain moving for
Cairo I don't know it has we care yeah
he's going to school in dentistry yeah
he wants to be a time but I feel like
Carol's obsessed and I feel like she
will I don't know if it'll be immediate
but I feel like she really is down for
him and he's obsessed with her and she's
he's the only one that can handle her
like I'm spicy just like I need to just
one to handle me so he is they're gonna
make Terra seemed so ready to find
something real don't know she would she
would go fast like Ray was the first
time and I was like girl like slow it
down the first time she took her time
like waited to kiss then I'm like that
special moment so like she needed every
step of that way to get to that point
with ray do you know how did you how did
you feel about when she kissed Anton and
she hadn't kissed right yet that broke
my heart that was like waiting for her I
got me ready to kiss her why did they do
that okay yeah yeah I love when Ray's
mom came in she said I don't think she
called him out you should have been
looking hard to call her out she was
like you know we are here to see what
the best connection is so many people
get scared of that sometimes but yeah I
think with us we understand that I think
what you're hearing is they're like no
no ray was all in let's talk about the
lovely Dylan and Alex
here's the thing I uh I can't always
tell what Dylan's thinking because he's
like so chill and a lot of the time
watching the season I I knew she was
really into him and I wanted him to
really say he was into her how real do
you think his feelings are 100% okay I
like Alex was my best friend in there at
cash and dill and we're like besties so
we all hung out this kid was like she'd
fall asleep on him and he just
be like rubbing her head like watching
her like it was so genuine I think they
just had like a different way of like
showing their emotions so like goofy
okay
and he was kind of talking about okay
we're two hours away but we're gonna
make it work what do you guys think
about Dylan and Alex's chances after the
island together I think that like a good
chance I don't think they gonna get
married like I think Zach and Elizabeth
the very Carrigan like dog I think they
have a good chance but you know why
we're getting comments and questions in
from you guys and Logan's is perfect
Logan says is Weston and Emily's love
for real
they were fourth and look Emily was
pretty late to the house but you guys
are both shaking your head no you don't
think so no I think they're gonna have
the most fun and most toxic relationship
out of all the four oh yeah he always
points out like he's like they have
argued so much like it's so toxic and he
likes the spice but I think she's a
little bit too much spice and that he he
gonna have to like back away that lawyer
mentality is like he not he not the
objective like it was telling when they
were trying to make that shoe rack and
then structure like you're getting so
mad I was like okay but what do you
think about how they've got like this
mutual sense of adventure like could
that keep them together did they just
need more time what what do you think I
I don't know like there was a lot going
in there that time no comment cut it
sighs Sheila says I love Karen Raye I
agree um Haley wants to know Kyra will
you still talk to Weston you guys had a
friendship and maybe a connection that
was even more than that yeah I mean I
hope that we do you never know you
really hope that you do yeah okay if you
are even close it's hard sometimes if
you have the chemistry with someone to
like keep you know yeah I mean there's
just a lot of confusion I think time
will tell you know time will tell well
let's tell us something about Kyra and
her potential man
Kira Kira Kira you were a standout
sought-after lady from the start and
then along the way you broke a couple
hearts but there was one man that you
couldn't push away or keep away
literally let's take a look at your
moments with Cashel my catching the
vibes over yeah you have a good poker
face but like I can't really read you
okay move this pillow
cuz it's blocking my box
actually a really good choice I'm going
in are you going in what do you think
three days ago we was we were tight yeah
it's it's definitely yeah
Eric Katrina and Cashel your time on
love Island is over no I've not given up
on loving you you know it's still out
there something will come up I don't
know I just doesn't feel right being
here without him I can honestly say that
I love gosh like honestly I was like at
least we live in the same place and I
don't know maybe in the outside world we
can see what happens here tell us what
was going through your mind were you
legit surprised when cash I had no
freaking clue I had no clue I left and I
was like I just want to call him I just
want to call him so I was like okay
here's a phone and then he just freaking
popped up I almost broke my leg like I
went down like I was scared for you dude
no I had no clue
well Kasia was in here for our recap
show just last week this would have been
before he came and surprised you and of
course I said Cashel what are your
feelings for cure like I said I still
have made your feelings for her so then
we saw on the show that you still had
feelings for him that you missed him do
you regret not just being with him
throughout the season you picked Eric
you picked other guys I know I mean I
was up front with cash from the start I
can be a little bit of a crazy lady and
you know a lot of people thought I would
like was way older and they're like I
was one of the youngest ones in there at
the time so I mean where we are now I
wouldn't change anything because what we
went through and like the process of it
all where we are now is like where I
want to be so could I've changed some
things and could things have done
differently for sure and you know I was
open about that but where we are I'm
grateful so where are you now
oh he's not man
did you guys talk is he your boyfriend
we have not had that talk but you know
it's the second that I met the kid I
always said like it was easier to like
look in his eyes and talk to him and I
did not expect that going in there at
all and I think that's what freaked me
freak me out and I just like tried to
push it away but I'm like not doing that
anymore I just want to like not do that
because I do that in the past we saw we
and you talked about it you talked about
look sometimes when they get close to
people I push them away I mean when you
guys were watching were you just
thinking Keira belongs with Cashel or
did you see her with somebody else
potentially once Eric walked in and I
was like oh Eric's on a thousand like I
like there he was pursuing her and she
liked it I'm like no they're together
but then when Kash gave her the necklace
I literally looked at her and said oh
she's gonna be messed up like the rest
of the season there's nothing here can
do because that necklace he could have
left on a bitter note was like no like
but I called you every step of the way I
was like nope
this is self-sabotage and she really
likes him and then I did say cuz I
didn't believe this you need to push
them away just so they can prove that
they really want you and then you'll be
okay so now that you guys have had that
moment now you're gonna be obsessed with
him and you can like he left and it was
never the same it was like a girlfriend
getting like you know during a breakup
and she just like spins off the wheels
like that's what happened to me in there
like after he pretty much what I needed
oh for sure that had what was it that
really made you realize I mean after he
left you were in tears then at first it
was a you know I understand that in
there you get really close to people
really fast and at first I thought well
she's just so close to them and then I
realized no no this feelings are still
there what was it that made you know
wait I have romantic feelings for this
guy and I wish that I was still with him
right now
because he was easily like i can say my
home there and the second that he left
it did not feel like I had my person he
understood me on like so many levels and
that's what freaked me out he would say
things and we would connect and he just
never judge everyone in the villa could
say that he was always like you we never
couldn't meet like a guy like Kosh until
you met him and I just I fell like hard
and that freaked me out and he laughed
and I was like dude but I was still
freaked out and scared and I was
I want to finish my journey in here I
wanna like see a connection like it
scared me it freaked me out
had to finish that for yourself I had to
finish it for myself you know it was so
bold and so scary going in there that
that process like I'm so grateful I was
able to like go through it and learn so
many things about myself the island is
real but it's 100% I also want to ask
you mean he comes he surprises you we
know you got a long flight home we know
now you live 20 minutes away from each
other how much time of you guys spent
together since leaving and and what was
that plane ride home like oh we've been
like glued to the hip since he surprised
me we stayed together that night we like
flew back together the entire flight
like we didn't speak we just like talk
talk talk because it's the first time
without the cameras and we just like
when in yeah we haven't seen each other
like he had been seeing me for you know
we keep it watching his life and like
just to see that he was the same person
on the outside and I was the same person
it was like oh this is so dope you know
that's amazing if he asked you cuz this
is something we're getting the comments
and the question is are you ready to
because we have like and I want to give
our audience some credit they have some
puns going a hundred will you in cash
will make music together he met my
siblings the other day he was like
freaking out they're like come play with
us I love it and also mieka says didn't
they all win in their own way look that
tape yes but let's talk about some
connections that didn't work out so much
Kyra you shared a vibe we'll definitely
call it a vibe with Weston we are going
to replay your initial conversation with
Weston and then also what Weston kind of
just said about things take a look I'm
always gonna have a crush on you know
youth don't promise you're Christian so
rewind to a first week you would have
pursued me more that a day obviously
catchin on the way I wasn't gonna be
like yo do you think you didn't pursue
me because hush was your boy for that
time 100% he's so happy that you did
that
[Music]
I was like curious to see what it was
because being here like this like I knew
exactly how she felt with cash so for
her to come say like she had feelings or
whatever like I knew that that wasn't
ever gonna be a thing because I was like
she's so into cash so I really feel like
she was almost stirring the pot if it
was never gonna be a thing then why did
he bring it up to me so many times that
was my question okay I think he brought
it up to you so many times because you
put it in his mind
I didn't he brought up - no no I'm
saying once we saw on TV it was he said
Oh what are you doing that got all these
guys dragged to you and you said not
enough for you not to be on me that put
his mind right switch cash it's like
Matt two nights after cash left I'm
crying freaking everyday and everything
he brings into the fiery pit and he's
like I just want to put this in your
head like it was a regret not pursuing
you more in the beginning oh and he was
like I just want you to think about if
we had coupled up if I had put one more
time would we have maybe gone down this
road and like what could have happened
and I was like I have no clue like gosh
just left we are such good friends I
have no clue and he's like think about
it so when you try to warn miss Emily
about this and she obviously did not
take it too well how was the relation
did it recover with me and Emily Emily I
don't know like I'm asked all of us our
opinions and we were too upfront and
honest with her you know so me and her
were always chill the girls and they
were really good at keeping it chill I
don't know if she's show with me I think
we're chill
oh love Islands can be love connections
and it can be friendships and it can be
I love triangle that's for sure more
comments coming in from you guys you
love to this season we love hearing that
by the way love island season - we'll
talk more about that later and of course
we have to wrap up the first season of
love island of the summers most
addictive series with all the best
moments that we simply love to take a
look mm-hmm Kesha is your type please
step forward
[Music]
tough luck immediately working out with
Zack in a reenactment of broke bath
mountain oh it's always nice kissing
Kira
it's always nice eight nine nine and I'm
not handing out ten my god what I think
it's huge you get it away dirty that
happened to me and I turned out me huge
collision like a football you hit you
know and I didn't even know it also the
babies flying out lands on the ground I
look down I didn't think it was my baby
but it was my baby
Challenge made so many gifts that I will
be using for years to come I mean that's
an unforgettable moment so we had Zach
and Liz bethey winners of season one of
love island we have some love
connections care and casual but we got
to go to you guys because our big
brother alumni I mean this is a real
real love story let's catch up with you
- where are we at on wedding planning is
your city are holding each other's hands
adorably like we're still in the midst
of planning and like going through the
guest lives in the venue and location
we're still doing everything right now
so yeah I'm overwhelmed yeah I'm not
like I've never been the type of girl
that's like dreams of my wedding I
haven't been planning it since I was
five so now that it's finally here and
everybody asking me these questions are
like what colors you want
what kind of this do you want what venue
I'm like I don't know like it is
overwhelming so I've kind of like
stopped for a second but we're going to
get going yeah I mean nobody is ever
like wedding planning is so much now my
sister is not like she's like I can't
wait I already have the colors picked
out and all the stuff and I'm like so
how much time do we have we have time
[Applause]
sometimes it's easier to just think okay
what are musts what are your wedding
must look like three things that you
think we got to have it like this on the
day is it a DJ is it a certain type of
dress what are three months our DJ has
to be live we gotta be we're gonna be
jam it in there I want to look swaggy
and like all black I want vanilla cake
and I want you think that what give her
the power I need the most glam dress
that you ever want to see so I've been
modeling since I was 14 and I have been
in so many wedding dresses just like
over the years so my wedding dress has
to be like better than all of them if
you see me in a photo shoot and it looks
better than my wedding day I don't have
a fit okay what else so you know it's
gonna be Liz
hey but I need just me my man and on
ordainment of marriage oh I love it you
guys are such a good example of what can
be but we come from you guys on
challenges like the food challenge and I
know I like it was you love [ __ ] I loved
and that's what we won we're such weird
I love that messy one but it all worked
out it done Michelle says yay love
Islands so happy Zack and Elizabeth were
able to find each other we agree you
know all right everybody on that note we
have officially filled our love tank for
this summer
but never fear love island will return
next summer for season two and if you
want your shot at love CBS is casting
apply right now at cbs.com slash casting
plus if you missed any of these
unbelievable moments you can binge the
whole season of love island on CBS all
access and we want to give our special
thanks to Bailey Dalton to swaggy
Williams to miss Kira green for being
here and all three of you for letting us
in on your journeys to find love
everybody follow them on social if you
don't already and one more time from our
cozy Cabana here in california i'm
lauren zima until next time stay cool
sexy beaches bye
[Music]
[Music]